so so I will say on this show we try to  stick to the rule rather than the  exception and that's not the majority  okay I'll get to the rule 63 of Youth  suicides yeah are from single mother  homes 90 of homelessness and runaway  children are from Singapore you can't  put that on the mother 85 of children  who show behavioral disorders are from  single mother homes 80 of rapists with  anger problems are from single mother  homes 71 of high high school dropouts  are from single mother homes 70 of  youths in operated institutions are from  single mother homes 80 of all the use  that in prison are from single mother  homes  guys why is your immediate reaction  you're blaming the woman when he's just  reading a stat